from the recent movies it would be
like to name a rival
not sure how it's in English but in
Russian it calls for such
Fast and Furious
that's difficult uh I think uh probably
if I had to pick one since it's probably
a historical favorite as well I would
probably say Citizen Kane I feel like
it's a very good representation of
Journalism from from years past why do
you have to pick that question that's
just a very tough question I would say
maybe Memento maybe Gladiators up there
um
Pulp Fiction but it's a tough choice
that's a difficult one
but probably uh a Soviet movie
no
in the mood for laughs
Terminator
that's too hard too hard to just I
should watch more movies